بعدك انطفى العالم ما بقى بالشوارع نور
وين انت يا حبيبي هذه كلمات يتذكرها الناس
للفنان الكويتيه عبد الكريم عبد القادر
عبد رحيله عن عالمنا بعد صراع مع المرض
يلقب الفنان الراحل عبد الكريم عبد القادر
بالصوت الجريح بعد طرحه اغنيه اجر الصوت
في عام 88 وتسعمائه توفي عن عمر ناهز واحد
وثمانين عاما قضى سته عقودا منها في تقديم
الفن الاصيل لجمهوره في العالم العربي
والخليج خاصه
قبل ثمانيه اشهر اجرى الفنان جراحه في
القلب باحدى مستشفيات الامارات وطمئن
جمهوره بفيديو على وضعه الصحي لكنه تعرض
لازمه صحيه اخرى تسببت في وفاته يوم
الجمعه بمستشفى جابر بالكويت كيف تلقى
الكويتيون خبر رحيل الفنان حمزه الحردان
يقول لك عبد الكريم عبد القادر لطالما
كانت اغانيه رفيقه الطرق الطويله واكثرها
طرق الخارجيه الكلمات التي يختارها يرحل
مع اللانسيان يرحل مع سهيل نسال الله ان
يتغمدك بواسع رحمته رشاد الصيادي قال لك
انطفاء الصوت الجريح وجرحنا رحيله وداعا
الفنان الكبير عبد الكريم عبد القادر رحمه
الله تغشاك بندر جازي قال لك عبد الكريم
عبد القادر هذب الحزن خليجيا قدمه كما يجب
ان يقدم
في حياتنا الصفحات الكبيره وذكرياتنا نقيه
كما هي روحه قال الوداعه
علي الاسدي قال رح
[موسيقى]
ليله ويا عساك تعود